open ear wireless earbuds are becoming
more and more popular and soundcore just
released their new aoit lineup and today
we're going to be comparing the new aoit
Pro to the shocks open fit earbuds now
these things are very popular on the
market and they come in at
$180 so not bad but the airit pros are
$170 and they offer a lot more features
which we will look at now now if that
sounds a little bit too expensive for
you soundc also has the regular AO fit
which have a lot of the features of the
pros um and these come in at 130 bucks
so you guys can check out the links down
in the video description now you guys
can see that the shocks box is smaller
you basically get the earbuds a charging
cable and a little baggie inside of
there whereas the aoit pros come with a
little extra so let's go ahead and open
this up man that's held on there really
good bam that is off nice presentation
like always and look at that something a
little extra let's just go ahead and get
this case out first and we'll unwrap it
and all this is eco friendly material as
you guys can see the case is a little
bit larger and we have this button right
over here and when you press it bam it
pops open just like that let's try that
again without looking that's pretty cool
what do you think V that's awesome it's
a little presentation we have that led
light right there and those are the
earbuds now in the Box we also have
these little accessories which you don't
get with the shock so this is a band
that can go behind your neck and it's
interesting that the material is like a
stiffer kind of springy wire and as you
guys could see this is also adjustable
so you can actually pull it one way and
the other so you can adjust the the fit
to get it just right and that gives you
a little bit of extra security with the
um actual earbuds so I have them set up
like this nice and lightweight and the
material is like this uh braided kind of
cable definitely feels really nice let's
go ahead and get take these uh earbuds
out of here and as you guys can see
there's little labels to make sure they
say charged up while they're waiting for
you to buy them let's grab the earbud
right here and we could just pop these
on bam they are on let me maybe do a
little bit of
adjustment and then now we have that
extra protection so if you're outside
working out running quickly even if
something slips off you're not going to
be losing them and having it on I don't
even feel that band whatsoever it's just
kind of hovering there and it's nice and
lightweight and with these it's so
interesting with these open ear earbuds
um that you don't don't have that
stuffiness in your ear whatsoever you're
not plugging up your ear a lot of people
have issues with having something inside
their ear canal the pressure that builds
up so with these you do not have that
and of course it gives you a different
experience as far as listening which
will talk about in just a little bit so
these aoit Pros are very comfortable
surprising because you have that a
little band that comes down that of
course has your battery in there as well
and I just feel a little bit of a touch
around my ears and both of these have
this soft touch rubber material on them
which is really nice because that is
making that contact so the airit pros
are nice and comfortable let's try out
the shocks here and compare them and you
guys could see that the shocks do have a
little bit of a Slimmer band and a
smaller little piece here for the
battery and putting these on very
comfortable it actually has a little bit
more tension on my ear so I feel them a
little bit more even though uh it's
Slimmer but also very comfortable and
nothing sticking into my ear canal and
the reason why the airit pros are a
little bit larger and slightly heavier
is because they have way better battery
life and a really large driver inside of
there the airfit pros get 14 hours of
battery life compared to seven for the
earbuds themselves and then 46 hours for
the case compared to 28 so as you guys
see that is a huge difference in terms
of battery life and for fast charging 10
minutes gives you 5 1/2 hours with
airfit Pros compared to 2 hours and the
new airit Pros also get better ipx5
water resistance they also include ldac
support and support for spatial audio so
soundcore really packed in a ton with
these new earbuds and now let's go ahead
and get these paired up I'm going to go
into my settings app and then of course
uh sound core has their app where you
can tune a lot of things just like like
shocks does as well so here are the AIT
pros of course we get some instructions
on how to put them on and for the
controls now the Sound Cores have a
physical button right over here so you
have physical controls compared to
having touch controls with the shocks
now the touch controls work great the
only thing is if you're adjusting
something putting something on you can
accidentally tap it whereas with
physical controls it requires a little
bit more pressure in order to use your
regular controls to pause skip song
things like that and now let's go ahead
and compare them and I'm going to start
out testing out the microphone to see
how good the call Quality is this is the
microphone quality of the shocks open
fit using their four builtin microphones
and this is the microphone quality of
the soundcore aoit pro with their four
builtin microphones you guys let me know
your thoughts about microphone quality
and now let's get into the actual music
quality test now as you guys know these
open ear design uh it's kind of made so
that you can actually have full
awareness of what's going on you can
hear everything and you can still listen
to music without feeling all plugged up
so we're going to start out with this
EDM
track somewhere
unfamiliar bring me back to where we
started get me out of
M
[Music]
all right guys so we definitely had some
differences now first off listening to
open ear earbuds it's definitely a
different experience from sealed ones in
one area where these kinds of earbud
struggle is base now thankfully both of
these actually do a good job but the
shocks they do get a little bit louder
if you go into the app and enable it uh
which I did without it it was super
quiet but then some of the highs start
falling apart and the base kind of can't
keep up where the 16.2 mm drivers in The
Sound Cores they're able to keep a nice
consistency throughout so even though a
little bit quieter the sound quality is
better and the vocals are a little bit
smoother and now we're going to listen
to this Rock track which is going to be
a lot more difficult for all headphones
but especially open air ones if you want
that loud Rich
thumb the now no one could ever bring us
down but if you think you got what it
takes to
[Applause]
[Music]
start all right guys now for that track
we have a very similar experience both
actually did surprisingly good and we've
tested other open ear uh wireless
earbuds before and these do a good job
now once again the shocks can get louder
but I wouldn't want to listen to them
there because a lot of the highs once
again start falling apart the vocals
kind of start getting a little crunchy
um whereas The Sound Cores you get a
little bit more base especially on that
crazy um drum beat setup and at the same
time they sound a little bit smoother as
well and I wonder if the reason why the
volume is locked out um out of the
get-go is just to meet that battery life
um whereas the I didn't have to go in
and enable a louder mode because of the
larger battery capacity that is built in
so there you guys go these are the new
sound core aoit pros and they have that
attachment cable as well to keep them
more secure so if you're looking to get
a set of openair earbuds um to not block
out your ear canals I would definitely
take a look at these and then if you're
on a little bit lower budget where you
don't need that cable um you can also
take a look at the regular AIT we're
going to have all the links down in the
video description below go ahead and
click that Circle above to subscribe
check out one of those videos right over
there this been Max and I'll see you in
the next
[Music]
one